to be honest though that that mindset
doesn't do well in a marriage yeah
you're not in a relationship correct no
I get it or even a relationship I mean
you it doesn't matter you if people you
can break up with your boyfriend yeah
you can yeah but it's like but it's like
once you've got kids involved right it's
a lot it's well it's not about you
anymore I'm like if I want if I have
kids with you if I'm staying together
yeah well regardless right but even like
when you have kids it's like you can't
do what you want to do anymore no but I
think I also was being selfish because I
was like I want to do my career and I
felt like I was being stopped I was
always being told you probably can't do
it yeah you probably why are you doing
this yeah I mean you you probably were
yeah but that's the whole point is like
you usually have to give up something to
be in a relationship yeah